Welcome to 3ABN Today Bible Q&A. My name
is J. D Quinn. I'll be your host. I love
this program, Bible question and answer.
It's a lot easier to ask for an answer
than it is to try to figure out the
question, you know. But I'm with my
family here and I want to introduce each
one. I think most everyone that's
watching knows who we are. Pastor James
Rafferty, welcome. Good to be here. J D
from Central California skyping in.
Looking forward to our program today.
Good to be here with you, Shelley, and
Pastor John. Amen. And Pastor John is in
between the two. Yes. Every time we get
questions, it always says to us, "Hey,
you didn't know that, did you?" And then
we learn something. Thank you for your
questions. Amen. Amen. Amen. And
Precious Shelley Quinn. Thank you,
honey. This is We love your questions.
Thank you for participating. And as you
said, sometimes the challenge is there
questions that we could teach for an
hour on and we're trying to distill it
to three minutes, but thank you so much
for participating. Amen. And of course,
we're mentioning questions. And where
those questions come from? Those
questions come from you. And we are
eager to receive them. And boy, some
questions are deep questions and some
are relatively simple. But a question is
a question. But how do we get them? If
you choose to uh text, you might send a
text in to
618-2283975. Or perhaps you'd rather
email it. That's Bible QA at uh
3ABN.tv. Excuse me. I'll say that one
more time. Bible
QA3abn.tv. and we also use Instagram and
that's
3ABN_official. So that's three ways and
I'll mention it again probably in about
15 or 20 minutes. But anyway, please
send those questions in. And as we start
this program off, I'm going to start
with prayer and then we're going to get
into the questions. Father, as we come
together today in the name of Jesus,
thank you. Thank you for this
opportunity, Lord, that we can talk
about you, that we can ask about you,
that we can brag about you. And so,
Father, be with us. Be with all those
that are watching. We give you praise
and glory in the name of Jesus. Amen.
Amen. Okay, Pastor James, we're going to
start with you. Your first question
is, Jesus real name is
Yeshua. Why do people call him Jesus?
and is it okay to call him that? The
same question for Yahweh and God. And
this is from Susan.
Well, thank you Susan for that question.
You know, the name of Jesus and its
pronunciation is English. And in the
original text, Jesus comes from a Hebrew
origin, Yeshua, as you mentioned. And
the Old Testament equivalent of Jesus is
Joshua in the English. So the Old
Testament Yeshua in the Hebrew means
Jehovah saved and it also refers to that
Jewish leader Joshua who followed the
death of Moses. Now this meaning Jehovah
saved is transferred to the New
Testament uh name of Jesus uh because
Jesus uh parents were instructed by the
angel of the Lord to name him Jesus
which means Jehovah saves. Let's look at
those verses. They're in Matthew 1:es 18
to 21. Now the birth of Jesus was on
this wise when his mother Mary had been
betrothed to Joseph before they came
together. She was found with child of
the Holy Spirit. And Joseph her husband
being a righteous man and not willing to
make her a public example was minded to
put her away privately. But when he
thought on these things, behold, an
angel of the Lord appeared unto him in a
dream, saying, Joseph, thou son of
David, fear not to take thee Mary, thy
wife, for that which is conceived in her
is of the Holy Spirit, and she shall
bring forth a son, and thou shalt call
his name Jesus, for it shall be, for it
is he, excuse me, that shall save his
people from their sins. So we see then
from the Old Testament to the New
Testament, the exact pronunciation of
the Hebrew word Yeshua changes due to
the language. In Hebrew, Joshua is the
Greek easus.
From the Greek to the English language,
we land on the name Jesus. And that is
why we address Yeshua as Jesus. Because
we don't speak Hebrew and we don't speak
Greek, we speak English. And so that is
why we use English for the word Jesus.
And of course we do that with the rest
of the Bible also which by the way is
another reason you should sign up for
our school of disciplehip sod this uh
fall in October because one of the
subjects taught is how to learn the
Hebrew and the Greek meaning of words
that we read in English. So answer the
question yes it's okay to call Jesus
Jesus especially if you speak English.
Now, if you speak Spanish, you will call
Jesus Jesus. Or if you speak French,
you're going to call him Jazu. Or if you
speak German, Jesus. I hope this was
helpful in answering your question,
Susan. Amen. Amen. Thank you, Pastor
John. Your first question. Since people
are being troubled by other so-called
beings, if they're not from outer space,
then where are they from? Thank you for
your question. Let me read a couple of
things. First of all, I've said this
kind of a smi a smiling way. Beings from
other worlds don't want to come down to
earth to risk being assaulted. I mean,
this is not a friendly world. This world
has been racked by sin. And the Bible
does say that God created other worlds.
So there are other existing worlds where
sin has never invaded. They don't want
to come down here. But the question is
where do they come from? Jesus made a
statement in Matthew chapter 24 that's
very apppropo on in relation to this
topic. says in Matthew 24:4, uh, "Take
heed that no one deceives you." Now, why
is deception a part of this
conversation? What do these spirits, so
to speak, have to do with deception?
Well, there was a war that began,
Revelation
12:7-9. And you have to ask yourself the
question, where do these demons or
spirits come from? Revelation 12:7. And
war broke out in heaven. Michael and his
angels fought with the dragon. And the
dragon and his angels fought, but they
did not prevail, nor was a place found
for them in heaven any longer. So where
do they come from? There are beings that
were in heaven. They were cast to the
earth. Verse 9. So that great dragon was
cast out. That serpent of old called the
devil and Satan who deceives the whole
world. He was cast to the earth and his
angels were cast out with him. And
Shelley and JD and and uh Pastor James.
So, we have an earth that's filled with
the fallen angels who have had a career
of deceiving individuals. Second Peter
2:4 says, "For if God did not spare the
angels who sinned, but cast them down to
hell to deliver them in chains of
darkness to be reserved for judgment."
The word there hell is tatarus, a
spiritual world, a world where they're
bound, where their powers are limited.
We can't see them. They are existing in
a dimension that we cannot see. But in
the ministry of Jesus, they were very
apparent. people possessed by that. And
you find these are various ways that
they manifest their fallen power through
physical illness, mental impairment, the
spread of false doctrines, spiritual
warfare, possession, and also deceptive
appearances like ghosts, apparitions,
signs in the heavens, like people think
they're aliens. And so when we see this
happening, we must understand that
Revelation 16 is coming to pass. Verse
13. I saw three unclean spirits like
frogs coming out of the mouth of the
dragon, out of the mouth of the beast,
out of the mouth of the false prophet.
What are they doing? For they are the
spirits of demons performing signs which
go out to the kings of the earth and of
the whole world to gather them to the
battle of that great day of God
Almighty. So if you believe that these
are aliens or these are spirits showing
up as your relative or somebody that
looks familiar, these are simply spirits
of demons with the ability to transform
themselves and look any way they are. As
Paul says in 2 Corinthians 11, 13- 14,
don't be surprised for Satan himself
transforms himself into an angel of
light. So the bottom line is be weary
because these are not flesh and blood
creatures. We're not wrestling against
flesh and blood, but against spiritual
host of wickedness in heavenly places.
Amen. Amen. Well, well stated, Shelley,
your first question. Colossians 2:16
says, "Therefore, let no one judge you
by what you eat or drink or with regard
to a feast, a new moon or Sabbath." What
does this mean for the observation of
the Sabbath? And this is from Hosea.
Hosea, what a great question. Let's
distinguish between the difference
between annual Sabbaths which were feast
day Sabbaths and the holy seventh day
Sabbath that is weekly that belongs to
the Lord. The heart of the old and the
new covenants in both the heart of the
old and the new is the ten commandments.
But now the old covenant which was also
known as the book of the covenant or the
book of the law it had civil ceremonial
and uh social laws that cottified those
ten commandments. Now under the old
covenant they had several seven
seven annual feast days and these were
considered Sabbath rest whether they
occurred on the seventh day Sabbath or
not. They could occur on Monday, but it
was Sabbath rest. So those seven were
special holy
convocations. And the first two, it was
the first and the seventh day of
unleavened bread. Then there was
Pentecost, trumpets, the day of
atonement, and the first and the eighth
day of the feast of tabernacles. Those
seven, they often referred to them as
annual Sabbaths or as feast days. The
new moon was also on the feast calendar.
All of these simply
foreshadowed Christ's ministry. They
symbolically pointed toward him. Hebrews
10:1 says the law and we'll see it's
talking about the old covenant book of
the law in context having a shadow of
the things to come and not the very
image of the things can never with these
same sacrifices. These feast days had
sacrifices, food and drink offerings.
And it says they can, they're just a
shadow of the things to come. They can't
with these same sacrifices which they
offer continually year by year, make
those who approach perfect. So
Colossians 2, here's your question.
Colossians
2:13-17, let's read it. You being dead
in your trespasses and the
uncircumcision of your flesh, he has
made alive together with him. Having
forgiven you all your trespasses, having
wiped out the handwriting of
requirements that was against us, which
was contrary to us. The old covenant law
had curses listed in. It was on the
outside of the ark as a witness against
them. He said, "He has taken it out of
the way, having nailed it to the cross,
having disarmed principalities and
powers. He made a public spectacle of
them, triumphing over them in it." So
this is a purpose statement. In other
words, for this reason, based on what I
just said, that this was nailed to the
cross. Let no one judge you in food or
drink or regarding a festival or a new
moon or Sabbath with a little s which
are a shadow of the things to come. But
the substance is Christ. So these annual
Sabbath feast is what Paul is referring
to. This was the ceremonial law that
pointed toward Christ's redemptive work.
And it's distinct from the moral law,
the ten commandments, especially the
weekly Sabbath that was established at
creation. And we'll continue in
eternity. Amen. Thank you. Great answer,
shall we? Pastor James, second question.
Can you please explain Mark 4:12? I'm
struggling to understand the part that
says, "Otherwise, they might turn and be
forgiven." And this is from Lisa in
Jamaica.
Well, thank you, Lisa. In Jamaica,
Mark's version is harder to understand.
It says, and we're looking here at Mark
4:12, that seeing they may see and not
perceive, and hearing they may hear and
not understand, lest at any time they
should be converted, and their sin
should be forgiven them. Now, in my
opinion, the Gospel of Matthew does a
better job bringing out the meaning,
especially when we look at the context
of the this conversation. Matthew talks
about the same conversation in chapter
13. And we're going to read verses 13-
16. Jesus says, "Therefore I speak to
them in parables because they seeing see
not, and hearing they hear not, neither
do they understand. And in them is
fulfilled the prophecy of Isaiah, which
saith, by hearing you shall hear, and
shall not understand, and seeing you
shall see, and shall not perceive. For
this people's heart is wax gross, and
their ears are dull of hearing, and
their eyes they have closed. Lest at any
time they should see with their eyes,
and hear with their ears, and should
understand with their heart, and should
be converted, and I should heal them.
But blessed are your eyes, for they see,
and your ears, for they hear. So the
point that Jesus is making here is and
again he's speaking in parables is that
he wants only those who have a genuine
heart to and really desire to be
converted to be saved and will to
understand. The Pharisees were trying to
find fault with Jesus and they just
wanted to use his words to accuse him.
So they were not converted and they
didn't want to be converted. They didn't
want to be healed. They didn't want to
be forgiven. They didn't want to be
saved from their sins by Jesus. They
didn't care to be saved by for from
their sins by Jesus. They didn't believe
in Jesus. And so Jesus spoke in parables
so that they would not use his words
against him. He was basically saying if
they were willing to hear with their
ears and hear with their heart and be
converted and be healed, they could be
because even the disciples came to Jesus
and asked the meaning of the parables
and Christ told them what the meaning
was. But the Pharisees weren't
interested in coming to Jesus. They
weren't interested in asking the
meaning. They were trying to find fault
with Jesus. You know, the Bible says,
and this is 1 Corinthians chapter 2,
11-14. For what man knows the things of
a man save the spirit of man which is in
him? And of course, we talked a little
bit about that before the program when
Ronnie was talking about, you know, his
son and how he knows him because he's
just like he is. You know, we know
ourselves, right? And it goes on to say,
uh, even so, the things of God knows no
man but the spirit of God. Now we have
received not the spirit of the world,
but the spirit of God, which is which
the spirit which is of God, that we
might know the things that are freely
given to us of God, which things also we
speak, not in words which man's wisdom
teaches, but which the Holy Ghost
teaches, comparing spiritual things with
spiritual. But the natural man receive
not the spirit of God, the things of the
spirit of God, for they are foolishness
unto him, neither can he know them,
because they are spiritually discerned.
So, like the conversation that Christ
had with Nicodemus in John chapter 3
where he said, "Nicodemus, John 3:3, you
need to be born again. You will not see
the kingdom of God." Now, what that word
means, see, it doesn't mean you're not
going to go to heaven. It it's talking
about discernment, spiritual
understanding. You're not going to
understand the kingdom of God unless
you're born again. Uh Nicodemus was a
Pharisee just like these other
Pharisees, but his heart was open. He
changed. He was transformed by the
spirit of God. He understood the words
of Christ when he spoke. Well, he didn't
understand them at first if he spoke
about the new birth, but he recognized
the need for a new birth. You see, Jesus
came to save men. But the Pharisees
didn't want salvation from Jesus. They
only wanted to find fault with his
doctrines and speaking in parables did
not allow them to understand unless they
wanted to truly be converted and healed.
They didn't want that lest they be
forgiven, lest they be converted. They
were the ones that didn't want to be
converted and therefore they were the
ones that were not pursuing a fuller
understanding of the truths that Jesus
was speaking in parables. But you and I,
we want to understand those truths and
God will give us the understanding
through his Holy Spirit. I hope that
helps, Lisa. Amen. That's great. Love
it. Pastor John, do all believing
Christians go to heaven? And the second
part of that, are there characteristics
of a saved Christian? And this is from
Rosa. Thank you, Rosa, for that
question. Very good question. To all
believing Christians, belief is
intellectual. Operative Christianity is
evidence that you are not only out of
Egypt, but Egypt is out of you. And I
want you to remember that, you know, the
Lord finds us in one condition, but he
transforms us into another. And that
transformation is gradual. So when you
say you are saved or you are a Christian
that believes in Christ, there ought to
be evidence. The first evidence is the
the first evidence is the fruit of the
spirit. Galatians 5 22 and 23. Love,
joy, peace, longsuffering, gentleness,
meekness, patience. But there's
something else the Lord looks for. James
2:18 talks about this. But some will
say, "You have faith and I have works.
Show me your faith without your works
and I'll show you my faith by my works."
Now, the works of the Christian life is
not works of the Christian, but Christ
working in us. For it is God who works
in us both to will and to do of his good
pleasure. We're not saved by works at
all. That is a judicial act by God
alone. That's justification. But
sanctification now becomes a partnership
where you are laborers together with
Christ. And he's producing in your life
evidence of that salvation. That's why
Titus 1:16 says about the Christian they
profess to know God but in works they
deny him being abominable disobedient
and disqualified for every good work. So
a person might say I believe in God but
then you look at their lives and you say
that's not a Christian I want to be like
and so Christianity is a common thing
but living the Christian life is a
spiritual thing. And this is something
that's not just a profession that I'm a
Christian, but a transformation that I
live as a Christian. Christ is living in
me. That's why Romans 6:16 is so
significant. The Bible talks about this
daily decision Christians must make. Do
you not know that to whom you present
yourselves slaves to obey, you are that
one slave whom you obey, whether of sin
leading to death or obedience leading to
righteousness. Now, this is not the lost
person. This is the decision we make
after we're born again. That's why Paul
says when he saw the challenge of being
a Christian, he said, 'Oh, wretched man
that I am. Who will deliver me? But
here's the key. He said, "There is
therefore now no condemnation to those
who are in Christ Jesus." But here's the
difference. Who walk not according to
the flesh, but according to the spirit.
So what does it mean to be a believing
Christian? And here's significant.
Matthew
7:21-23. Don't get works and
Christianity mixed up. Because a lot of
people could do a lot of Christian
things, but Jesus said these words. Not
everyone who says to me, Lord, Lord,
shall enter the kingdom of heaven. But
he who does the will of my father in
heaven. Many will say to me in that day,
Lord, Lord, have we not prophesied in
your name? You can do that. Cast out
demons in your name. You can do that.
And done many wonders in my name. You
can do that. But then I will declare, I
never knew you. Depart from me, you who
practice lawlessness. So doing Christian
things doesn't mean you're a Christian.
It is Christ doing his work in you and
transforming you that is the evidence.
And this comes only as you submit your
life to Christ. He will end what he
began. Amen. Amen. Boy, all three of you
answering great questions here. Shelley,
your next question.
Some say that the New Testament is an
embellishment of the Old Testament. Are
there any scriptures that speak of
Christ alone and not of Israel? And this
is from Wesley in Texas. Oh, Wesley,
what a question. And I uh encourage you
to watch Spotless, the everlasting
covenant on 3ABN or get the book
Spotless, experiencing the everlasting
covenant through righteousness by faith
because you'll see Jesus is from Genesis
to Revelation. The Messiah is the entire
Bible is a progression of God's
revelation of his everlasting covenant
of salvation by grace through faith in
the Messiah. The old covenant contains
the new. The new covenant explains the
old. Revelation 13:8 says Jesus is the
lamb who was slain from the foundation
of the world. This plan has always been
in place. So when you go to the Old
Testament right away, Genesis 3:15, as
soon as there's sin, Genesis 3:15
introduces the seed who's going to
destro the deliver who will destroy the
devil. And then there's a
substitutionary sacrificial system that
God puts in place. This points to Jesus
in righteousness by faith. God ratified
by vision with Abraham in Genesis this
covenant of righteousness by faith.
Abraham believed God. It was credited to
him as righteousness. And then we get to
Exodus. Well, he also renewed the
covenant with Abraham's son Isaac and
Jacob. Then we get to Exodus 2:24 and it
says, "God heard the crying of the
Hebrews who were in slavery and he
remembered his covenant with Abraham,
Isaac, and Jacob." The entire sanctuary
system, by the way, is the plan of
salvation all pointing to Jesus. And
this is what's interesting. As you
transfer from the Old to the New, the
narrative of the New Testament begins
where the Old Testament leaves off. The
last book of the Old Testament, Malachi
in 3:1 says, "The Lord whom you seek
will suddenly come to his temple, even
the messenger of the covenant, speaking
of Jesus Christ in whom you delight."
Now, we go over into the New Testament
and listen to this. Luke 1:54, Mary is
bearing Christ in her womb and she it
breaks into song. It says, "God has
helped his servant Israel in remembrance
of his mercy as he spoke to our fathers
to Abraham and to his seed forever." And
then in Luke 172 and 73, Zachcharias who
was a priest, he was the father of John
the Baptist who was yet unborn. But he
said when he knew that she was pregnant
with the Messiah, he said God was
performing the mercy promised to our
father. Remembering his holy covenant,
the oath which he swore to our father
Abraham. Jesus fulfilled 125 plus Old
Testament prophecies. And this
fulfillment is evidence of his
messiahship. Prophecies like Daniel 9
24-27.
That's the 70we prophecy actually
precisely predict the date of Christ's
ministry and death. So fulfilled Old
Testament prophecies as we read those
and then see what happened in the New.
This is our foundation for trusting
God's word. Isaiah
42:6 and Isaiah 49 verse8 back in the
Old Testament says that Jesus the
Christ, the Messiah is the covenant. God
says, "I will give you as a covenant to
the Gentiles." And I encourage you to
read Isaiah
52:13 through Isaiah
53:12. This is the servant song that
details the Messiah's suffering and
death. It describes Christ's suffering
and death and his resurrection with such
specific detail that you know only God
who knows the end from the beginning
could have authored it. And it gives you
absolute trust that Jesus fulfilling all
of these there's no way he could have
been an impostor. Amen. Man, I'm so
impressed these questions. You are doing
a wonderful job. Once again, let me
remind you of uh how you can send uh
your questions into 3ABN. If you want to
text it, it's
6182283975. Perhaps email is Bible
QA3abn.tv and Instagram is
3ABN official. We look forward to
receiving those questions from you.
Pastor James, your third question.
Should we return tithe on gifts of
money? And this is from Frank in
California.
Thank you, Frank in California. We're
both there. I'm glad to be your
neighbor. Uh you know, we receive uh
questions similar to yours uh so often.
We know many are listening and are
wanting to understand this. And so what
I understand is that pensions or
earnings or wages or disability or
inheritance or gifts or winnings any
increase that we receive above what
we've paid into uh for example if you
paid into social security for for many
years and you paid tithe on your gross
income you're not going to pay tithe
again on that money when it comes back
to you but you would pay tithe on
anything that comes back beyond what you
put in. Um all of the money that we
receive is eligible for tithe and
offering. You know, we return tithe on
our increase, not just on our wages
earned. Sometimes that increase would in
include gifts. Now, as you know, tithe
is God's. It's not ours. Uh so, it's not
something that we give to God. Rather,
it's something we return to him. Tithing
is not a payment or a bill. Uh rather,
it's a faith statement in God. When we
return our tithe, we say God owns
everything. And uh nothing we receive
comes from us. It all comes from him in
the first place. That's 1 Chronicles 29.
and verse 14, of thine own have we given
you. All things come of thee and of
thine own have we given you. And so when
someone gives us a gift, that gift
actually comes from a giving heart which
has its source in God. God impresses
people to do good and to give uh
generously to others. And so we know
that God blesses us through other
people. And when we return tithe on
gifts that God has impressed people to
give us, we are accepting his challenge
to prove him according to Malachi 3:10
and and see if he will not open up the
windows of heaven and pour us out a
blessing that we won't be able uh to
receive. So we return tithes um because
that gives us the privilege of
partnering with God to take the gospel
to all the world according to first
Coron uh 1 Corinthians chapter 9. We
return tithe in order to lay up treasure
in heaven. And that's Matthew 6:20. We
return tithe uh even though it's a small
amount um to to tell uh the world in God
that we place our full trust in him to
take care of us. And you can see that in
Mark 12:41-44 where the widow uh gave
her might. Just a little tiny might, but
it was all that she had. And when we
return tithe, we let go more of our
self-rust and more of our earthly
possessions and we trust more in God. Ma
uh Matthew 6:33 says to seek first the
kingdom of God and his righteousness.
All these other things will be added
unto us. You know what we eat, what we
wear, where where we with shall we be
clothed, and where shall we live. God
will take care of that. If we put God
first, he'll take care of us. And we
also return tithe just to devest
ourselves of more of our selfishness. um
we allow God to step into our lives in a
very significant way because money is of
course a very significant part of who we
are and how we survive in this world. So
I hope Frank that's helpful in answering
your questions. Remember you can't
outgive God but it's fun trying. Amen.
Amen. Thank you very much
James John. Pastor John, will those who
accept Jesus as their Lord and Savior
receive eternal life even if they did
not observe the Sabbath day? Okay, thank
you for the question. The answer is yes
on the following conditions. Here's the
key, very significant. You know, the
Sabbath, let me just talk about the
Sabbath first of all because the the
context of the question, will they
receive eternal life? Eternal life is by
grace through faith in Jesus Christ
alone. That's a gift. He who has the son
has life, not he who has the Sabbath has
life. But when you become a child of
God, this is something that is so
significant. Uh we live in a world today
where the Sabbath has been separated
from the ten commandments as though it's
a separate command all by itself. But
Jesus said, "If you love me, keep my
commandments." And many people say,
"Well, he didn't say, "If you love me,
keep my Sabbath." Well, remember the
Sabbath is the fourth of the ten
commandments. It's not something
separate. And Jesus observed the
Sabbath. His disciples observed the
Sabbath. The apostles after the
ascension of Jesus observed the Sabbath.
So it's very important that if you're
part of a fellowship where the Sabbath
is being taught as separate from the
commandments, it's deception. It's not
separate. It is a sign of of
relationship between you and the Lord.
Ezekiel 20:12. It's a sign that he is
the Lord that sanctifies us. It is a
sign that we are his and he is our Lord.
Ezekiel 20 and verse 20. Now on the
other side, what about those who never
heard about the Sabbath and they're
serving God? Well, Acts 17:30 and 31
talks about a time of ignorance. Now,
there are those who throughout the
centuries, throughout millennia, in
times of darkness, during the dark ages,
never knew about the Sabbath, didn't
understand the Sabbath, and they were
taught to honor Sunday. And the Bible
says in Exodus, Acts
17:30, truly times of ignorance, God
overlooked. King James version says God
winked at. Well, they didn't know that.
But look at the conjunction. But now
commands all men everywhere to repent.
We're not living in an age of ignorance
because God has appointed a day in which
he would judge the world in
righteousness by the man Christ Jesus.
So he is saying, "Wait a minute. This is
not the ignorant age. You're not in the
dark ages. You should read the word of
God." And something that's very
important, Shelley and JD and and Pastor
James, is we're not going to be judged
just on what we know. We're going to be
judged on what we could have known. Now
when you say when you see a sign say
high voltage and you close your eyes the
voltage doesn't go away. When the Lord
says remember the Sabbath to keep it
holy and you close your eyes the
holiness does not go away. Your
obligation now becomes complicit
complacency and you purposefully ignore
what God command you to do. You're no
longer ignorant. James 4:17 to him who
knows to do good and does not do it. To
him it is sin. And 1 John 2 vers4 he who
says I know him and does not keep his
commandments is a liar and the truth is
not in him. So, if you're in a
fellowship that doesn't keep the
Sabbath, don't seek reasons not to keep
the Sabbath. Seek reasons to be
obedient. Why? Because the Lord created
the world. There's no reason for a 7-day
week outside of the last week, outside
of the last day, being blessed as a sign
between us and God. It's the only day he
sanctified. And then he said in Mark
2:27, "The Sabbath was made for man and
not man for the Sabbath." So honor the
Sabbath because you love the Lord and
you want to be in his kingdom eternally
where the Sabbath will be kept. Amen.
Very well stated,
Shellyley. Number three, does the Bible
say that once saved, you're always
saved? The gentleman that sent this in,
Bill from Texas says, I say yes, but my
wife says no. I tell her that once
you're a child of God, you're always a
child of God. Just like my kids will
always be my kids. Even if we were to
backslide, we are saved in my opinion.
What does the Bible say about once saved
always saved? Bill, this is an excellent
question and to answer it this quickly
is very difficult. I do have a one-hour
teaching on this. If you go to 3ABN,
look up once saved always saved question
mark. That's a sermon I did. The Old
Testament, as I said earlier, is a
progressive unfolding of the salvation
of the everlasting covenant of salvation
by grace through the redemption that is
by faith in Christ Jesus. And it points
to a
relationship that a covenant
relationship that is rooted in love,
trust, and obedience. God makes and
keeps all of the covenant promises. 2
Corinthians 1:20. All of his promises
are yes and amen in Christ. But he
invites us into covenant relationship
with him. And this
relationship requires that we abide in
Christ where love is
motivated uh or love motivates our
obedience and loyalty to his covenant
law. John 14:15, if you love me, you
obey my commandments. Now, Romans 8:38
and39, this is where your I agree with
what your wife's conclusion is, but
Romans 8:38 and39, you've got a hint of
this. God, it said Paul says nothing can
separate us from the love that is
in Christ Jesus, God's love for us. The
covenant is unbreakable from his end as
long as we are in Christ. The spirit of
adoption isn't this isn't a fragile
relationship. This is a I mean God
doesn't unadopt his children. Yet he
never forces love. And the covenant
requires a love connection with him. And
we grace does not eliminate free will.
We must choose to remain in Christ in
covenant relationship. Scripture warns
about those who turn away from him, who
reject his ways. Jesus even said in John
15:6 that if we don't continue to abide
in him, walking in his footsteps, we are
going to be cut off. 2 Chronicles 15:2,
God reminds us, "The Lord is with you
while you're with him. But if you
forsake him, he will forsake you."
Exodus
32:32 and
33, God says, "The one who sins, I will
blot out of my book." See, this is not
just God's the same. He doesn't change.
He's the same yesterday, today, and
forever. He keeps covenant with those
who keep covenant with him. He says in
Ezekiel
33:18-20 that the righteous who turn
from the righteousness will die, but the
wicked who repent will live. Revelation
3 feet 3:5 Jesus says, "He who overcomes
shall be clothed in white garments. I
will not blot his name out of the book
of life." This is not about insecurity.
It's about
accountability within grace and
salvation is absolutely assured for
those of us who are in Christ. You can
have assurance of salvation. 1 John 5 11
through13 says he who has the son has
life. So believing in Christ isn't just
mental ascent saying yes I've accepted
him once as my savior. Believing in
Christ is to be living in Christ. Ellen
White wrote this. She said, "It's not
God's will that we be distrustful and
fearful because you feel sinful or
unworthy." You just simply say, "I have
no merit, but I present the blood of the
spotless lamb." That's the faith I live
by. Page 100. Amen. Very good. Pastor
James, your last question. In 1
Chronicles
21, David numbered the children of
Israel. Why did so many Israelites die
for the sin that David committed in 1
Chronicles 21? This is from Norma in
Florida.
Thank you for that question, Norma from
Florida. You know, there are two
biblical reasons that can be seen for
the death of so many Israelites for
David's sin. And when I say two, there's
there, you know, I'm not I'm just
suggesting that there's at least two
reasons. Only God knows why so many died
along with uh because of the sin of
David. But the reason number one, and
the Bible's really clear on this, the
Bible teaches that that our sin has
consequences, and often those
consequences affect other people.
Divorce affects our children. They are
innocent sufferers. Uh drunk driving
affects other drivers. uh people are
killed or or maimed all the time by the
choices that drunk drivers make.
Gambling affects families. Uh we don't
sin in a vacuum. Uh sin brings pain and
suffering untold to other people in this
world. But number two, often our leaders
are a reflection of our own sins. Now in
this story, we see a protest from Joab,
who's David's general, uh David's second
in command, that is. um because Joab saw
the folly of numbering the people. But
like David, the people in general also
seemed to like the idea. In other words,
there wasn't a general protest or an
uprising against what David did. Uh
there were times when the people would
resist their leaders because they felt
their leaders were doing wrong. But this
was one of those times when the people
did not resist when they went along. And
so we can see in this that the people
themselves are simply reaping the
consequences of a sin that they have
enabled or that they're in agreement
with. Now it's important for us to
understand that God is merciful even in
judgment. You know he gave David these
options. Uh there were three of them and
and uh David actually chose an option
that was a reflection of God's grace and
goodness. You know, he said uh 1st
Chronicles 21:13, David said unto the
Lord, "I am in a great strait. Let me
now fall into the hand of the Lord, for
great are his mercies, but let me not
fall into the hand of man or into the
the uh judgment of pestilence." That was
one of the other options. And so, what
we see here is David trusts in the Lord.
And this was why David was a man after
God's own heart because he always
committed himself to God even when he
made terrible mistakes. He put his trust
in the Lord. And in that David
interceded for his uh people and even
that judgment that God brought upon him
was cut short. So it's also important
for us to understand there are many more
people in this story who did not die.
God extends uh judgment um but he never
does it unfairly upon those who are not
guilty. And so in a very real sense all
of us are guilty. All of us deserve to
die according to Romans chapter 6 and
verse 23. But God has given us this gift
of mercy and grace and longsuffering.
And I I believe that each one of us uh
can appreciate God's loving kindness
toward us, his mercies toward us which
are renewed every morning. So I hope
thank you for your question, Norman. I
hope this answer has been helpful. Amen.
Great. Pastor
John number four. According to first
John 5:16 and 17, which sins lead to
death and which do not? This is from
Jonathan. I'm going to read those verses
for you. 1 John 5 16-1 17. If anyone
sees his brother sinning a sin which
does not lead to death, he will ask and
he will give him life for those who
commit sin not leading to death. There
is a sin leading to death. I do not say
that he should pray about that. All
unrighteousness is sin and there is a
sin not leading to death. You know,
Shelley, our friends here, I I did some
research on this because I don't want to
just shallowly say, well, if you repent
of it, it's not a sin leading to death.
All sins need to be repented of. But
there's a very deep background that I
have and I that's why we thank you for
these questions because sometimes it
allows us to go into the chamber that we
haven't unlocked before. This was so
significant. Now, the writers who
responded to this number of Bible
commentaries I looked at, uh, there are
those that sin that have not fully
rejected the Holy Spirit. In this
instance, it's a sin not leading to
death. There is still hope for them.
They may even be an open apostasy, open
defiance to the point of walking away
from the truth. In such
cases, those that
remain have a responsibility to
intercede for them. Let me go ahead and
read a passage and I'll just talk about
the sin that does not lead to death.
Galatians 6 verse 1 and 2 talks about
this. Brethren, if a man be is overtaken
in any trespass, you who are spiritual
restore such a one in a spirit of
gentleness, considering yourself lest
you also be tempted. Bear one another's
burdens and so fulfill the law of
Christ. Now going back to the thing
about unintentional sin. Now,
intentional sin, we we talked call this
premeditated. I've been planning to do
this, but Numbers 15:25 talks about this
unintentional sin. And verse uh 15,
chapter 15, verse 25, so the priest
shall make atonement for the whole
congregation of the children of Israel,
and it shall be forgiven them, for it
was unintentional. They shall bring
their offering and offering made by fire
to the Lord, and their sin offering
before the Lord for their sin. There's
still a sacrifice needed. But what
happens? This is something so
significant. I can I'm going try to
cover it all. If they're o in open
defiance, they still have an opportunity
to be saved. There are five things we
must do if a person is in that case
because it depends heavily on how we
respond to a person who can still be
recovered.
One, do not enter disputes and arguments
with them. Two, be gentle and patient
with them. Three, if they are willing,
correct them by showing them the truth.
Four, hopefully they'll come to their
senses. Why? Because they unknowingly
were taken captive by the enemy to do
his will, and they don't even know it.
Here's the evidence for what I just
said. 2 Timothy 2:es 23 and 20 to 26.
But avoid foolish and ignorant qu uh
disputes, knowing that they gender
strife. And a servant of the Lord must
not strive, but be gentle to all, able
to teach, patient in humility,
correcting those who are in
opposition. If God
perhaps will grant them repentance, so
that they may know the truth. That's if
they're willing to know it. And that
they may come to their senses and escape
the snare of the
devil, having been taken captive by him
to do his will. There are those who are
recovered eventually. Sometimes it takes
years, Shelley. Sometimes it takes a
long time because pride gets in the way.
They dig their heels in. But the Lord is
more long-suffering than we are able to
outlast his longsuffering. When we come
to that point, what should we do?
Repent, therefore, and be converted that
your sins may be blotted out. So the
times of refreshing may come from the
presence of the of the Lord. Acts 3:19.
Now on the other side, you've got to
confess all sin. If we confess it, he's
faithful and just to forgive us and
cleanse us from all unrighteousness. But
when you are in open rebellion and
choose not to confess it, there is no
room for forgiveness because you are in
recalcitrant o disobedience and you have
grieved the Holy Spirit.
Very very very good. Shelley, yes. Your
fourth question, can you please explain
2 Corinthians
37-18? Why does it say that the law
written in stone was abolished? And this
is from Jay in Ohio. Jay, I'm going to
take you through a careful reading of
this and we're going to find out that it
doesn't say that the law is abolished.
In 2 Corinthians chapter 3 verse 6, Paul
is setting up a comparison between the
old covenant and the new covenant. And
both of those covenants have the ten
commandments at the heart of them. But
what he said, both of these covenants
are from God. Both are glorious, but one
is fading and the other is eternal. What
Paul says is the letter kills. Speaking
of the old covenant, book of the law
known as the book of the covenant or the
law of Moses. These had civil, social,
and ceremonial laws in them that
codified the ten commandments. And they
had blessings and curses. In Deuteronomy
27:26, it says cursed is the one who's
does not confirm all the words of this
law by observing them. So then Paul in
verse six contrasts, oh the letter
kills, but the spirit gives life. Now
let's get into second Corinthians 3:7.
If the ministry of death written and
engraved on stones was glorious so that
the children of Israel could not look
steadily at the face of Moses, what are
they looking at? The face of Moses. They
couldn't look steadily because the glory
of his
countenance which glory was passing
away. What is Paul saying? Exodus
34:29. Moses had been up the mountain
again for 40 days. He God had renewed
the covenant that Israel had broken when
they worshiped the golden calf. And now
he's renewed this covenant. He's given
Moses the Ten Commandments written with
God's own finger again. Moses comes
down. His face is shining. And the glory
of the old covenant, this Mosaic
ministration pointed to Christ. It was
seen in the types, the symbols, and the
rights that were in the ceremonial law.
The glory reflected in Moses' faces face
was because of his fellowship with God.
And that glory after he gets out of
God's presence began to fade. The glory
of his countenance was passing away.
It's just like the glory of the old
covenant as the Jewish system. It will
merely reflect reflected Christ. And
that glory of the old covenant was
temporary. It was fading away. That old
covenant was kept outside the ark in a
pocket that stood there as a witness
against them. But get this, the passing
glory is not from the stones, the ten
commandments, the two tablets. Those are
the character of God and their glory
never passes away. Matthew 5:17, Jesus
says, "Do not think that I've come to
destroy this law. It or the prophets. I
did not come to destroy but to fulfill
to fill it to the fullest. Now 2
Corinthians 3:8, how will the ministry
of the spirit not be glorious? He said,
if that old law was glorious, think of
the ministry of the spirit. For if the
ministry of condemnation, that's the old
covenant and its civil, social, and
ceremonial laws, had glory, the ministry
of righteousness exceeds much more in
glory. So when we think about what the
new covenant did that, you know, I love
Colossians 2:17 says that those feast
days and all those ceremonial laws were
a shadow of Christ. That's what Hebrews
10:1 says. They were just merely a
shadow. But when Christ came, his life,
his death, his resurrection is so much
more glorious. And the new covenant is
the ministry of righteousness. It is not
a lawless gospel at all. Hebrews 8:10
tells us that God writes his laws on our
heart and in our minds. So we have a
much greater glory in the new Christ in
us, the hope of glory. And I leave you
with Romans 8 verse4. It says that the
righteousness of God's law of love is
not discarded. Rather, it is fulfilled
in us who walk by the spirit. Wow. All
three of you have answered some great
questions. Want to take just a couple of
minutes for an address roll and then
we'll come back with two minutes of
final thoughts.
If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at
bibleqa3abn.tv. That's
bibleqa3abn.tv. You may also text your
questions to 6182283975.
That's
618-228-3975. Be sure to include your
name and where you live and then watch
through Bible Q&A for answers from God's
word. Welcome back. Now we got time for
additional comments. Guys, this was
absolutely fantastic. Uh James, you got
an additional comment? Yeah, just for
the question from Jamaica. Lisa asked
about Mark chapter 4 and we looked at
Matthew chapter 13. Just a couple
thoughts here, a couple more verses. Uh
Matthew 13:16, "Blessed are your eyes,
for they see, and your ears, for they
hear." That kind of echoes the the verse
in Revelation 1:3, "Blessed are those
that read and and hear and keep the
things written herein." And then, of
course, John 3:19 and 20 when Jesus was
talking to the Pharisee named Nicodemus,
he said, you know, people don't come to
the light because they don't want to be
exposed because their deeds are evil.
And so the Pharisees didn't want to come
to the light, but we want to come to the
light. We want to receive the blessing.
And a lot of people don't read
Revelation because they don't really
want to understand that truth. But God
wants to encourage us to read and
understand these truths. He's not
keeping anyone from being forgiven or
converted. Amen. Pastor John, about the
Sabbath, you know, this is one of the
most beautiful gifts that Christians are
missing out on. It's a fellowship that
is unlike any other. The world is shut
down. Nobody's bothering you. this day
that the Lord blessed you enter you
enter under the canopy of a blessing
that is beautiful and until you're in
that relationship you don't know it
that's why the Lord says here's the
issue not what day you worship but the
question is the seventh day is the
Sabbath of the Lord your God the
question is who is your God if he's the
God of creation the Sabbath is your day
amen I just want to add uh if you've got
your pen jot these three scriptures down
three things Christ nailed to the cross.
1 Peter 2:24 says that he bore our sins
on the cross. So that certificate of
indebtedness was done away with. He bore
our sins. Romans 6:6 says, "Our old man
was crucified with him." So that old
nature was crucified. And Colossians
2:14-17 says that all those old feast
days, those old Sabbaths, those old uh
food and drink offerings were done away
with at the cross. Amen. I just want to
tell you very proud of the work that
y'all have put into this. Answers were
great. I want to thank each one of you
for watching, for taking your time, and
I just want you to know how much 3ABN
loves and appreciate you. Have a great
great evening.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Neiel.